while Texas is cracking down on the
historic number of Border crossers
entering our nation every day illegally
President Biden is blaming Republicans
for the sudden surge Biden claims he
would be able to quote shut down the
border right now if only the GOP would
pass his immigration Bill Republicans
say that's not true here's Florida
Governor Rona
Santos this border deal is a farce Joe
Biden already has the authority to shut
the border down he could declare it a
National Emergency he could stop The
Invasion cold if he wanted to he does
not want to he wants to let people in
this so-called deal uh purports to give
him tools so that he could actually
close the border the reality is is it's
green lighting up to 5,000 illegals
every single day that's 1.8 million plus
uh over the course of a year which
they're codifying into law is saying
that's an appropriate number of illegal
entries I think think the appropriate
number of illegal entries is zero and
our policy should reflect that yeah this
sudden appetite to fix the border is so
political by this President and he could
fix it by executive power yeah he did
this with a pen he could undo it with a
pen he chooses not to just like Governor
Ronda santz said there but this is also
important to note cuz we have an
election coming up Democrats want to
have the appearance that they've done
something without actually doing
something and they're able to do this if
Republicans get on board with this
border bill because if you go from
10,000 or 15,000 a day to 5,000 then you
can stand on the podium or the Lecter
and you can say that you cut it in half
and you're making great strides in
progress towards securing the Border
you're actually not but it looks like it
and to your average viewer or voter out
there they'll say you know what it was a
mess but Biden is working on it and the
numbers are already down 50% that is
such a fantastic start so that is that
that is crazy and so true you and I have
been at the border when it was starting
to get to 5,000 a day 5,000 is a huge
number too how do you think they got to
that number well let's keep in mind that
in the Obama days 5,000 was a high now
that's what we're willing to settle for
is 5,000 a day that also doesn't include
the Goda Ways by the way so that 5,000
number already astronomical already
unacceptable but that's not even the
half of it so Mark what do you say to
the critics uh on on the left to say
well Republicans just don't want to do a
deal they want to run on this Trump is
telling them they got to run on this so
and so forth oh you know Biden's got to
get this through right now well I don't
think it has anything to do with the
election I think maybe for some it does
but I think they think it's a bad deal
you know I mean Republicans even some of
the Democrats I no I think the
Republicans think that a lot of the
Republicans think it's a bad deal for
the reasons that Governor D santis ra so
if you think about this it it Bill
maluan reported this weekend that there
were
6600 uh border crossings on Saturday
right so that would have triggered this
deal if it went into effect and and
would have shut down the Border no
Asylum claims no anything everybody gets
thrown over there and that's fine that
would have that would might have lasted
for a long time so it would actually
have an impact on the border but the
problem is Biden has broken the record
every single year for the highest number
of border crossings last year it was an
average of 6, 767 a day so that would
triggered by this by this deal the year
before in 2022 is 6,493 a day so that
would have been triggered so the Border
would be shut down on most days but 2021
which was the alltime record in 2021 it
was only 4739 a day so that would not
shut down the border that would be okay
so what we what this deal does is it
codifies Biden's 2021 border disaster as
that's the new standard that's okay we
consider that unacceptable until every
year it got worse so it's actually
taking what Biden's least bad year which
was the at that point the worst year in
history and making that the legislative
standard for what's okay so Emily going
forward with all of this if this is
going to be what Biden considers to be
the new normal how do we live with four
more years we don't I mean I'm I'm sorry
I how do we live with the past three and
to your point building off of what you
said not only does the president want to
make it appear as if he's doing
something but he also wants someone to
blame he wants to be able to blame the
Republicans if the bill doesn't pass or
to say I laid it out for you where were
you when I needed you the reality is
that he signed 94 executive actions in
the first 100 days absolutely
dismantling all of that President Trump
had put into place to protect the border
so to disant as's point a it's all
within his control he could secure the
border right now it's within his purview
as the Supreme Court and other courts
have uh formalized or or um you know
confirmed and secondly he doesn't need
the Republicans but it's all going to be
back on their messaging so at the end of
the day we're still not going to win
it's still going to be he has done
nothing wrong he's done everything right
and it was all the fault of the GOP in
magga yeah you know something that you
said though um mark an Tammy I should
say this when you consider the numbers
that we've already dealt with why can't
a plan start there and consider the fact
that we might have to shut down the
border for all the years equal to his
presidency to get back to some sort of
normaly yeah you know he's unwilling to
implement the solution because he's in
search of a talking point and here's
what I mean by that the solution is very
simple he put forward 89 executive
actions to roll back Trump's border
policy in the first 100 days you can
undo all 89 of those you don't need
Congress so they're in search of a
talking point and he tried out the we
wanted to put forward legislation the
GOP wouldn't let us well you controlled
Congress for two years all Democrats the
Senate and the house that talking point
didn't work so the new talking point he
wants is the GOP rejected my deal that's
the talking point they want they were
floating and I assume it's Democrat
operatives who floated this polling to
political Playbook this morning that
showed 66% of the American public said
they had serious concerns that the GOP
is playing politics with the Border they
think this will work it will not work
cuz everyone sees the lawlessness
everyone knows who to blame it's
President Biden well look just look at
the populations in those 25 states that
are standing with Texas right now I mean
you've got half the country standing
with Texas taking on the federal
government over removing razor wire I
mean whose side is the White House on
right I wish they're certainly not
uniting the country I wish we could see
one courageous Democrat Governor step up
and say I'm with the GOP on this because
it's crazy it's your political Futures
at risk hey everyone I'm Emily compano
catch me and my co-hosts Harris vulner
and Kaylee mechineni on outnumbered
every weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or
set your DVR also don't forget to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
for daily highlights